der nahdistanz arnold und brot die
linkspartei unter sich zu zermalmen
sehen sie meinen erschütternden bericht
aus dem krisengebiet
[Musik]
dann müsst ihr euch von der linkspartei
muss sich damit abfinden dass es
demnächst die starke sozialistische
kraft in deutschland nämlich die spd
geht ja alles land wo du willst
im prinzip könnte ja könnt ihr einpacken
[Musik]
das tun wir auch
aber er ich habe so eine vision dass man
praktisch eine eine einheitspartei
wiederherstellen können zwischen den
linken und der spd
auf jeden fall den neuesten ihre idee
war noch nie da
sozialistischer einheitspartei
deutschlands sed
die lüfte zeit für eine einheitspartei
natürlichen sein weil das gut ist wenn
die spd auch von links unter druck steht
die stand immer von rechts unter druck
so sieht es heute aus es wird zeit dass
der druck umgekehrt wird dann sitze ja
auch wieder vernünftige sie sehen doch
schon die ersten anfänge der schon oft
links geblinkt und ist doch nicht
wirklich abgewogen oder hat das auto
abgewürgt wir freuen uns aber wenn sie
es machen und sie sind aber nicht bereit
bei der spd in dem wagen zu steigen dass
man dann vollgas in eine lichte zukunft
wert oder vielleicht auch über die
praktisch damals gesagt so soll die
linke soll es geben im osten ich
gestatte dass damit damit dann so
gesehen
die idee die auswüchse an der ganz
rechten rand damit die so ein bisschen
einkassiert werden und die ganzen
spinnerten und jetzt hier müssen wir
feststellen dass die afg sehr große
zuwachsraten hat das macht uns natürlich
sehr sehr traurig im westen da sind wir
völlig beieinander ist was ist denn da
los also braucht ihr mehr geld oder was
was können wir tun damit er endlich mal
geregelt kriegt die bevölkerung aus
toten
[Musik]
wir faszinieren mit den bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen sie können gerne mal hier
bei uns auf dem boden teppich ein
sternchen legen wir können es sich
aussuchen was sie tun würden wenn sie ab
morgen ein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen bekommen würden
ich würde sagen ich mach erst mal nichts
dann hänge ich so ein bisschen ab so
meinen interessen nachgehen und dann
würde ich auf reisen an wirkung schulen
entdecken neue lebens auf reisen gehen
zb und dabei dann ab und zu noch ein
wegstecken und noch zwei drei kinder
zeugen
ja das wäre so ein plan der so nach
meinem geschmack werden würde ich kinder
machen und dann auf reisen gehen mit den
kindern das jetzt hinter werden dadurch
wirklich bescheuert fahrräder für kuba
war was setzt damit auf sich wir sammeln
fahrräder gebrauchte fahrräder und dann
schicken sie nach über um auch mal ein
schwein zum schlachter zu bringen oder
in kinder in die schule zu bringen also
vielseitig einsetzbar und im ländlichen
raum schon wichtig auf dem fahrrad ein
schwein zum schlachter bringen ja durch
kein problem also ist das schwein und
dann hinten auch im gepäck hat ja und er
hat sich so fest und neue kräfte braucht
ja den hat sich migros zu spanischen
oder oder hat ein tandem zu sprechen
hinten drauf wäre auch möglich reichen
ich entwerfe aber dieses faszinierende
zukunfts gemälde das die linkspartei und
die spd zusammengehen zu einer
gemeinsamen starken kraft welche
personen in der spd passieren euch da
ganz besonders
dann heute tot sein
ja mit diesen schönen ins studio
klickt hier für weitere heute schon
videos und klickt moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]